headed to the mound for the raised
left-hander josh fleming it has been
a frustrating matchup with this seattle
ball club all year
oh there's strike three call down there
at the bottom of the zone boy that's a
tough pitch to deal with
and a comebacker
fleming runs it halfway and makes that
toss
and the first pitch tapped towards
second cloud up and out with the throw
it's a quick one two three first and
logan gilbert really fits well this year
for the mariners this is 14 start five
and two record era just over four
we've talked about a number of the other
bullpens but the mariners both finished
special there you go top of the zone
again good way to start
not that one though that's a big
strikeout number two for gilbert
and on the ground backhanded by toro to
jp and that'll do it for the race in the
first for the raise
with multiple base runners here in the
second inning and then open up mike
zanino
that is a well placed 95 third strikeout
for gilbert two down in the second
just don't let it hit a ring
nice play by dylan moore
mariners
scoreless as we start the third
catcher tom murphy
on the ground to second
wow up with it his throw to first
one pitch one out
and he has another strikeout there two
up two down
and the pitch that's down with the
runner on the move and there will be no
play as the ball pops away
counts full on crawford and moore gets a
stolen base
payoff pitch
up the middle that's going to play the
run kiermeier does have the good arm but
demo got a great start no chance
mariner's leading one nothing
rbi for jp crawford is 34th
stays with the pitch and drives it right
back up the
middle he's done a nice job against
left-handers this year
mentioned earlier he's a better luck
against fleming anyway
chopper off the plate might work
backhand it does work first and second
for the mariners and all of this
happening with two outs
ground ball left side wendell comes up
with it the throw to first and plenty of
time open up the bottom of the third top
of the order for tampa bay
a little humpback liner gonna be a base
hit laos gonna try to dig for two and
he's gonna beat the throw in a stand-up
double for brandon lau number 17
and just like that the rays
have a man in scoring position
there's ball four
and the first two men aboard here in the
third
lines it back into center field kelnick
on the run and that ball is going to get
by go all the way to the wall
loud's going to score
joy's going to follow him arose arena
goes to third and he pulled up a little
bit at third and the ball was mishandled
he might have missed an opportunity to
score right there
here's the ball too that if you're a
mariner fan you think kelvin's got to
catch it he got there and just missed it
and that ball gets by him look at this
he does a great job of getting there and
then just whips on the ball maybe it
caught the thumb of his glove
but it gets to the wall
and here's what we're talking about
you're waving loud you're waving joy
now you're waving i don't know who he
stopped troy was right in his face razor
clinging to a slim three to one lead as
he moved to the fifth inning
there's a check swaying and a little
soft liner down to third caught by
wendell
eyeball toward the line phillips on the
run he's there and makes the catch
brett phillips nice little route there
and
comes up and without number two
makes the catch big smile
gotta track it track it small short walk
coming up and then uh he said i had this
the whole way don't don't back away
you're safe with me
[Music]
crawford strikes out
boy that was a quick inning and a lot
going on 3-1
so let's see if the rays can add on here
on the ground fair by third
up the line and beyond the bullpen
toward the corner
rosarito will pull into second with the
stand-up double
breaking ball
[Applause]
throws him out
and that'll do it the double proved to
be harmless we go to the six three one
rage
the raise and mitch haniger gets the
inning off to a good start oh he's going
to get three here
into third
and he'll stop him right there there's a
break it's a pitch up in the zone hits
it hard that's a fast ball at 90 miles
an hour
[Applause]
rose arena having a great series but he
helped the mariners out there
jt chagwa is the new pitcher
and a lighter grab by franco what a
catch bronco diving to his right at
shortstop comes up with this one
[Music]
and there's franco just tracking it
a little dive sprawl backhand in the
hole
[Music]
some quick reactions right there 106
off the bat
and the backhand diving catch
1-1 to seeks
got it near that time got it deep right
field under track making the catches
phillips scoring
easily will be hannigan we got a one run
ball game nice job by seeker to pick up
rbi number 67.
two gone and here is mike zanino
yeah that's a shot back into center he
got hold of that one keltnik turns
around and it is gone
home runs straight away center
and the rays got another run to make it
a two-run game again
showing you his raw power forcing
fastball that is right down the middle
full extension
by zenino
and great contact out in front
and he knew it ray's lead 4-2 as we
swing into the eighth inning
hit hard the other way that's a base hit
extra bases for jp as rosarina
will corral it and that is a good start
to the mariners eighth inning bring the
tying around to the plate
and hard left field base hit
holding it third is jp crawford that's
going to bring the go ahead run to the
plate christler deals two and two
did he go
run comes in here's jp scoring as that
pitch gets away to strike out of france
we got a 4-3 ball game
and not only do they get pick up a run
and get a run closer but hannigan moves
up the second base and now he's in
scoring position
and it's lifted into right back toward
the track phillips is going to be there
coming back onto the turf and he makes
the grab
to retire the side ryan sheriff is going
to get
the first crack at it in his 11th ball
game eight in the third innings going to
close out the m's with the 1-1 lead
swaying
[Applause]
of jake fraley
here's the pitch to murphy sky
into center field
and kier meyer is there to make the
catch so a strikeout on three pitches
and then murphy going after the first
pitch skies to center
and he sends a high fly ball into right
camped under at phillips and the rays
won it
one two three in the ninth inning for
ryan sheriff
who will pick up his first save of the
year second career save
and the rays have
beaten the seattle mariners for the
first time this year